My name is Stephen Naron, and I'm
the director of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies,
and it's my pleasure to open the
second annual Geoffrey Hartman
Fellowship Symposium.
I hope this day will prove to be
an enriching and productive one.
I'd like to thank the Fortunoff
family, and in particular Joshua and
Esther, for being here today,
and all of the other donors,
Blaustein, Libby and Ross families,
and dozens of others, large and
small, who helped make the Archive's
work possible.
The Fortunoff Archive's Hartman
Fellowship program, now in its
second year, was established
in honor of Geoffrey Hartman,
passed away on March 14th, 2016.
An eminent professor of comparative
literature at Yale and the Fortunoff
Video Archive's long time faculty
advisor, Geoffrey's vision
and leadership helped build the
Fortunoff Archive into the
institution that it is today.
The Fellowship, now in its second
year is a 12 month fellowship,
postdoctoral fellowship, for a
single new PhD.
In this year, we expanded the
program to include a joint
fellowship with the Vienna
Wiesenthal Institute.
And I'd like to think Eva Kovacs and
her husband Janusz for coming all
the way from Vienna to,
to, to be here today to
celebrate this initial
VWI/Fortunoff joint
fellowship.
Eva is the research program director
at the Vienna Wiesenthal Institute.
The purpose of the Hartman
Fellowship is to provide scholars
with an opportunity to pursue
deep research in the Fortunoff
collection to advance their own
scholarship, as well as to produce
an annotated critical edition of a
testimony.
Now, this critical edition is
a testimony transcript with
annotations in an introductory
chapter.
This, these annotations
in this chapter are, are designed
to illuminate the complexities of
the narrative and to include
additional information and context
to help readers better
understand or grasp the complexity
of a document like a testimony in
our, from our collection.
The essay, the introductory essay
is designed to focus on the
significance of this testimony for
Holocaust history in general,
as well as the fellow's scholarship
in particular, and our hope
is that our fellows will also, after
leaving here, serve as ambassadors
to, for the collection as
they continue to use it in their
research and teaching
at the next institution that
they call home.
The critical editions,
I hope, unlock testimony
and make them accessible to a
broader readership and
encourage both scholarly and
educational use of these resources
at various levels.
We have two presentations today
and then will, each of them will be
followed by a Q&A and we'll take a
break between them as well so people
can get refreshments.
And the first speaker
will be Sari Siegel, who is our
second Geoffrey H.
Hartman fellow.
Sari has an M.A.
and a Ph.D. in history from the
University of Southern California.
And she received her B.A.
from Yale University.
Boola boola.
The Geoffrey H.
Hartman postdoctoral fellowship
brings her back.
She earned her B.A. in 2006.
In addition to receiving numerous
grants and fellowships, she has been
a fellow in residence at the Center
for Holocaust Studies at the
Institute for Contemporary History.
She's been a fellow at the Vienna
Wiesenthal Institute in the U.S.
Holocaust Memorial Museum Jack,
Joseph, and Morton Mandel Center for
Advanced Holocaust Studies.
She has presented her research on
Jewish prisoner physicians at many
conferences and workshops in the
U.S. and abroad.
Sari will be presenting her work on
the testimony of Edith F..
So please join me.
Oh, Esther. Sorry, Esther F.
So please join me in welcoming Sari.
Thank you for the introduction.
Stephen, I would also like to take
this opportunity to thank
you for the fellowship,
uh, uh opportunity
and to thank the donors who
have created this position
in the memory of the very
important scholar Geoffrey Hartman.
It has been a pleasure to be a part
of the Fortunoff Video Archive,
especially as it marks
40 years since the taping of the
first four testimonies
with this special series of events.
Thanks also go to Christy Tomecek
for her assistance with the clips
and to Debra Bush for her assistance
with just about everything else.
Esther was born Estera Nysenhauz
on August 16, 1908,
in Lodz, or Lodz, Poland.
On October 9, 1991,
when she was eighty three years old,
Esther sat for an interview
with Jaschael Pery at
the Museum of Jewish Heritage in New
York.
Esther grew up in a traditional
Jewish home which kept
kosher and observed Shabbat
but was not Hasidic.
She was fluent in Yiddish and
Polish, and attended
a private Jewish school with Polish
as the language of instruction.
Unlike the majority of her peers,
she was not affiliated
with youth groups or political
parties.
As a result of living, living
in a predominantly Jewish
neighborhood and attending a Jewish
school, she had limited encounters
with non-Jewish Poles and
did not personally experience
antisemitism.
As a result of the numerus clausus
that severely limited Jews'
access to medical education
within Poland, Esther traveled
to France.
She returned to Lodz with
her medical degree in
1933.
Interested in pediatrics, she
worked at a children's hospital
but then switched to a position
as a doctor for a workers union.
Shortly before the German invasion
of Poland, Esther married
a school principal whom she
last saw when he left for duty
as an officer in the Polish army.
He was captured shortly thereafter
and as a Jewish POW,
eventually set to the, sent
to the Wlodawa ghetto,
from which he was later deported
to Sobibor.
Esther and other residents of
Lodz, renamed Litzmannstadt
by German officials, were
forced to move into the city's
ghetto when it was first
established in February 1940.
She worked in one of the ghetto's
hospitals and as a member
of the ghetto's emergency medical
service, making house
calls in response to reported
medical emergencies.
She lived in the ghetto with her
mother and one of her brothers,
all of whom were deported together
to Auschwitz when the ghetto
was liquidated in August,
1944.
Over those four and a half years,
she and nearly all ghetto
inhabitants suffered from hunger,
cold, and fear of deportations.
This image shows the doctors,
nurses and emergency personnel
of the hospital on...
going to try to do the Polish,
Lagiewnicka Street.
It is unclear whether she is
pictured here.
In August 1944, during
the final liquidation of the
Litzmannstadt Ghetto, Esther
was deported, along with her brother
and mother, to Auschwitz-Birkenau,
where she spent five days in
a section designated for Jews
to be transferred to other camps and
utilized for slave labor.
When a call went out for doctors,
she identified herself
and was subsequently sent to work
as a doctor in Guben,
a subcamp connected to the
Gross-Rosen concentration camp.
Located on the current border
between Germany and Poland,
this camp housed young women
assigned to work on radio equipment
for the German Air Force.
After the camp was evacuated
due to the approach of the Soviet
army in early February
1945, she traveled several
days in an uncovered truck
and arrived at Bergen-Belsen
on February 15th.
She received an assignment
from the head prisoner physician,
but came down with typhus within two
weeks and was still recovering
when the British army liberated the
camp on April 15th,
1945.
She moved the short distance
to the Bergen-Belsen Displaced
Persons Camp, which was established
in nearby Army barracks.
Once she recovered, she
provided medical attention to her
fellow survivors.
Not desiring to return to her
native Poland, she decided
to volunteer to be among a group
of DPs to go to Sweden for
further rehabilitation.
They departed in July 1945,
and she continued her medical work
in Sweden, treating Jewish DPs.
Her work came to a halt, however,
once her fellow DP's had recovered
and dispersed.
She subsequently benefited from
the kindness of a prominent Jewish
doctor in Stockholm and
worked in his forensic medicine lab.
Over this period, she entered into
correspondence with
her husband's-- first husband's
best friend, who was living in
New York.
Shortly after he arrived in Sweden
to visit her, they were married.
And in May 1947,
she followed him to New York,
where she eventually set up a
medical practice in pediatrics.
She recorded her testimony for the
Fortunoff Video Archive on October
9, 1991, and
then for the Shoah Foundation Visual
History Archive on January
30, 1995.
So, why did I choose Esther's
testimony?
Given that my dissertation studied
Jewish prisoner physicians in Nazi
camps and then my next project
will examine Holocaust survivors'
provision of medical care
to fellow survivors in the early
postwar years, Esther's
testimony seemed like an ideal fit.
After all, she served as a doctor
in Guben and utilized her medical
training to help survivors in
Bergen-Belsen, and then
in DP camps in Sweden.
Upon further exploration though,
her testimony did not yield very
much insight into her medical work
in these venues.
Nevertheless, I decided to work
with HVT-2033,
because as a result of my
dissertation research, I was
attuned to a few threads
that appear throughout Esther's
testimony.
Furthermore, the threads align
with my methodological approach,
the simultaneous investigation
of Jewish doctors on micro
and macro levels.
Because Jewish doctors' medical
training provided them with
knowledge and the skill
set required to treat
the sick and injured in ghettos and
camps, their recruitment
and/or protection offers,
at least to some extent,
insight into the value accorded
to the lives of their prospective
patients.
In turn, one can discern
dynamics between the pursuits
of two different yet overlapping
initiatives: the exploitation
of the Jewish labor force and
the extermination of European Jewry.
This line of reasoning is not
without exceptions, of course,
as Jewish doctors were also
mobilized for the benefit of
German officials' own health.
However, my dissertation research
revealed that this motivation
was generally secondary
to the goal of exploiting the Jewish
labor force.
I can address this caveat, as well
as the impact of insufficient
medical supplies, in the Q&A.
So how can Esther's testimony
offer insight into the macro
level dynamics between these
two major initiatives?
The first three sites of her
internment are crucial.
The question of preserving or
liquidating Litzmannstadt Ghetto
was one of the key flashpoints
between the German officials most
intent on extermination
and those more invested in
harnessing Jewish labor power for
financial gain and/or for
the benefit of the German war
effort.
Esther's references to official
measures taken to preserve the lives
of ghetto doctors and to reinforce
the medical staff, more
specifically, the instructions to
perimeter guards not to shoot those
wearing particular medical insignia,
and the facilitation of the
recruitment of additional doctors
from the Warsaw Ghetto in
mid-1941,
communicate that doctors
had value to German officials
as possible preservers
of the labor force.
Furthermore, the ghettos
Vartegau location is
important as this Reich annexed
region of western Poland
was the manifestation, or saw
the manifestation of this conflict
in the simultaneous proliferation
of forced labor camps for Jews
in 1941, '42,
and '43, and
the operation of the Nazis first
extermination site Chelmno,
beginning in December 1941.
My dissertation research reveals
that each level of the civil
government in the Vartegau,
including municipal authorities
in charge of the Litzmannstadt
ghetto,
as well as officials in Berlin
and German businesses, the
businessmen, sorry, in
public and private industry
either instigated
or facilitated the transfer
of Jewish doctors from Berlin
to forced labor camps for Jews
in the name of preserving the labor
force.
When Esther arrived in Birkenau in
August 1944,
and during the preceding late spring
and summer months, the camp's
crematoria were working at and
beyond capacity
as transports arrived from
the Lodz and-- from the Lodz ghetto
and from Hungary.
At the same time, however,
new sections of the camp were
established to hold thousands
of new arrivals who were soon
to be designated for transport
to hundreds of camps
to help the German war effort.
So while her mother was immediately
dispatched to the gas chamber,
Esther was among those sent
to the so-called transit camps
within Birkenau, and she was
transferred to Guben only five
days later.
Her transfer from Birkenau
to serve as a doctor for Jews
working in a factory manufacturing
airplane radio parts, demonstrates
a clear interest in the preservation
of Jews' labor capacity.
The camp's location within the Reich
proper draws further attention
to the importance of the Jewish
labor force as the Jews
were brought back into the territory
that was previously declared to be,
and was meant to stay,
Judenrein, cleansed of
Jews.
Guben was just one of
around one hundred Gross-Rosen
subcamps, dozens of
which contained prisoner populations
comprised mostly or entirely
of Jews.
Once she arrived,
her experience communicates
that, at least to some extent,
the German official in charge of the
camp had an interest in the
medical treatment of the inmates.
Is the
volume, OK?
Yeah,
where, would it be from the computer
itself?
You would do it from here.
Let's see.
Didn't seem loud enough.
Let's try that again.
I remember, Cibalgine--
There we are! Thank you.
at that time was stylish, from Ciba,
Cibalgine is like an aspirin.
So I called, like holding on
something, Cibagine.
Alright I read the one word.
The 'ine.--' er-- gave
me the holding.
And I wrote 'aspirin.'
Oh, so there were the two things.
And sometimes a minute later, or
whatever, I wrote "cotton,"
"alcohol," "iodine,"
and that's all.
Maybe another word, I don't
remember. And she came
and she says to me,
"that's all what you ask right
now?"
Evidently, the female officer
in charge of the camp was prepared
to provide more supplies
as she asked Esther if the
doctor had listed all the supplies
she required.
Her experience echoes my findings
related to Jewish prisoner
physicians within the industrial
subcamps of Auschwitz.
Surviving doctors report that
on a variety of occasions,
SS medical orderlies or doctors
obtained requested medical
equipment or medications.
And the importance of the Jewish
doctors to the industrial program
is clear from their transfers
from Birkenau to the subcamps
and from one subcamp to another.
I would also like to draw attention
to a micro thread that runs
throughout Esther's testimony,
the conduct of Jewish functionaries
and the issue of judgment.
Although admittedly problematic
and thus a possible topic for
discussion in the Q&A, I'm
offering the following tentative
definition of Jewish functionaries:
Jews who held privileged positions
and carried out tasks that
in one way or another and to varying
extents, facilitated
the achievement of the German
officials' aims.
As such, they
existed in what Holocaust survivor
and author Primo Levi calls
"the gray zone," a, quote,
"poorly defined space where the
two camps of masters and
servants both diverge and
converge," end quote.
Recognizing the moral ambiguity
of functionaries' circumstances,
Levi cautioned against judgment of
such people writing, quote,
"This gray zone possesses an
incredibly complicated internal
structure and contains within
itself enough to confuse
our need to judge." End quote.
Esther's testimony offers an
entry point to discuss several
examples of gray zone figures
who, until relatively recently,
have presented scholars with
a taboo topic.
The Jewish police in the ghetto or
the Ordnungsdienst, literally the
order service, is one
group of functionaries whom Esther
discusses.
Interestingly, as you will see,
Jaschael Pery, the interviewer,
presses Esther to pronounce a
judgment, which is actually
a breach of Fortunoff Video
Archive's interviewer protocol.
Esther, on the other hand,
chooses to suspend judgment,
just as Levi suggests.
There are some people blaming
the behavior of the Jewish police
in the ghetto.
Do you have some opinion about it?
I have my opinion, but I
don't know how to explain
it, because some people-- I
say that I
prefer to die and not do
these things, but others say that
this is self-preservation.
So this is a question of-- I
have to think of it much more
because I wasn't in this position
where I was to do,
I would call it, the dirty things.
I did what I could.
I couldn't do more than I did, and
I couldn't save everybody's life.
But the other things-- eh,
let's say they-- they-- they-- they
collected the people to the
gathering places to be deported.
Now this was an order from
Rumkowski.
And then Rumkowski got the order
from the German.
So if you were a policeman, you
could have said "I don't want to do
it." So you would have gone
and you had a family.
So now I-- I-- I don't want to go
into this.
It's too complicated and too
hard to accuse.
I don't know.
Evidently, she recognizes
that moral calculus cannot
account for what amounts to a
choiceless choice, which
calls for the consideration of the
officers' families' welfare
and the harm that might come to them
if the officers were to disobey
orders.
She takes a similarly hesitant
approach to judgment in her
discussion of one of the most
controversial figures in the history
of the Holocaust, Mordechai Chaim
Rumkowski, elder of the
Jews or Judenaltester
of the Litzmannstadt Ghetto.
I don't know how right
he was, how wrong he was because
he obeyed the German.
And maybe if he would not obey,
would nobody remained in the ghetto.
But if you want to be honorable
and stand, like to say, die on your
feet and not to live on your knees,
you shouldn't have had this.
But this is good for individuals,
but not to-- so the
history will judge him, how right
or how wrong he was.
But being in the ghetto, he abused
his power too.
He was an older man and
he once was something in the
hospital. I didn't work in this
because I lived on one side of the
bridge and the doctors who lived
on the other side work at the other
hospital.
It was something with the nurses.
He was going and giving
hits one nurse, another nurse.
And so-- so the doctor who
was on chief
objected.
So he almost hit him too.
So these were inner things,
painful to mention too.
But history will judge this.
I am not going to say what was right
and what was wrong.
But was a lot of
abuses and a lot of
things that shouldn't have happened.
But as you say, you--
by-- it is self preservation.
I am not going into psychology
right now. I don't think so we
have-- and I don't want even to
be the judge of all of this.
She believes judgment should be
deferred until history renders
a verdict, yet by 1991,
when she recorded these words nearly
50 years after the ghetto's
liquidation, when would such
a verdict be pronounced and who
would be in a position to do so?
Why the need for judgment in the
first place?
Again, Pery asks Esther
to pass judgment on a group of
functionaries, but this time
when it comes to the ghetto doctors,
there's no hesitation.
How would you, looking backward
at what
you experienced there as
a doctor with your colleagues and
the circumstances you had there
in the ghetto, how would you
judge the action there
of the doctors in the ghetto?
You mean the doctors' behavior?
The doctors, how did they behave?
And how did they act there in these
circumstances?
I would say, very
decent.
Everybody tried-- you see, it's hard
to say to try and to do, because
there are two difficult things.
You were-- we had paralyzed hands,
what we did.
But nobody abused anything
but as far as I know.
And I am sure there wasn't
to abuse in any way
patients or neglect patients,
or to collaborate with German--
not at all, not
at all.
None of them!
Perhaps she was not aware, or
no longer recalls, but there
were ghetto doctors who, under
coercion, assisted Nazis
in mass murder.
Nazi officials required Jewish
doctors to perform medical
examinations on people
on deportation lists to
determine whether they were
appropriate candidates for the fate
that awaited them at a particular
transport's assigned destination,
either a forced labor camp
or Chelmno.
As a result, ghetto
doctors like Arnold Mostowicz
could only protect a few individuals
by finding them undesirable
candidates for the transport.
In other words, he and
the other doctors who were coerced
into carrying out this process
had to decide who would
be exempt from the transports.
And in doing so, they had
to determine who would live
and who would die.
While there was significant coercive
pressure on Mostowicz,
it was largely indirect,
originating with ghet-- uh,
sorry-- with German officials
and conveyed to him via the
so-called Jewish self-government
in the ghetto.
Circumstances were different
in camps, however, where
the SS performed direct
supervision and thus exerted
the coercive force directly.
Although Esther's testimony does
not afford much insight
into that dynamic, she
does discuss an act of
resistance.
Once in a while, came a German
official to check how
was there, and I kept a little bit
a double bookkeeping for
him. I showed the temperature
and everything a little bit on the
normal side.
And the real, I didn't show them,
because the majority had TB,
and I didn't want he should know it.
He didn't examine.
He only took it, so
I tried to save.
Through my work on Jewish prisoner
physicians, I have devised a
framework to add-- sorry,
to aid conceptualization
and discussion of these
functionaries and potentially other
functionaries behavior, the coercion
resistance spectrum.
Unlike Levi's gray
zone, it sets
acts of resistance firmly
in the discussion, and
it emphasizes the dynamic of
coercion as opposed to the loaded
and largely inappropriate term
collaboration.
The word 'spectrum' is not
indicative of an array
between polar opposites, according
to which a particular act could be
situated and categorized.
Instead, it serves to draw
attention to the wide range of
possible courses of action.
The thrust of the model is
what I call historicizing
the gray zone and drawing attention
to the shifts in behavior and
the changes in environmental factors
that influence a prisoner physicians
room for maneuver.
So in Esther's case, the
combination of the infrequency
of the SS doctor's visits
and his lack of interest in
personally examining her patients
enabled her to keep two sets
of medical records and thereby
potentially save the lives
of her patients with tuberculosis,
a diagnosis that could have been a
death sentence.
Given that Esther's testimony
offers limited insight into her
work as a prisoner physician at
Guben, and because typhus
largely kept her from medical work
at Bergen Belsen.
I am not able to approach my
introductory essay as I
had hoped when I first embarked on
this Critical Edition project.
I simply do not have enough content
to mobilize the coersion resistant
spectrum framework in my discussion
of her testimony.
However, as I have demonstrated
here, I am able to bring
my dissertation research to bear
in another way.
The insights I have gained through
my macro level work on prisoner
physicians enable me
to read between the lines of
Esther's testimony, and
address how her presence as a
doctor, as well as the
events and places she describes,
sheds light on the interaction
between two central
German initiatives during
the Holocaust: exploitation
and extermination.
In other words, I am able to address
the testimony's relationship to
the macro-scale narrative of
the Holocaust.
As such, I can point out
how the history behind the testimony
challenges the outdated and--
sorry, internationalist narrative
that based on the following,
Pery evidently espouses.
He asks, quote,
"Looking backward again, about
the starvation, and the illness,
and sickness, and the conditions
in the ghetto, do you
think that all this was planned
ahead by the Germans, the situation
in the ghetto before the
liquidation?" End quote.
Shortly thereafter, he adds, quote,
"I read somewhere that they did,
they planned it purposely this way."
End quote.
Consequently, as a historiography
of the functionalist, intentionalist
debate has given way to more
nuanced studies,
my critical edition essay will,
among other things, introduce
Jewish doctors as a lens
through which to view macro level
developments.
Thanks for your attention.
I look forward to comments and
questions.
Questions for Sari?
Maybe I missed something, but you
talk about Dr. Mostowicz.
Could you--
Elaborate?
Yeah, because it's a-- I don't know
the context.
Yeah. So he,
as a doctor in
the Lodz ghetto,
wrote a memoir.
So he sheds the--
Oh, okay.
--the most light on
what went on there from the
medical team.
So I can let
you know about that later if you
want.
No, I do know about it. I just--
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] The name was [INAUDIBLE]
Any questions?
Joshua?
What for you were the most
surprising revelations from
your studies? What were the things
that you thought you might find that
turned out differently?
Generally, when I, when I read the,
the summary of her
Holocaust trajectory and
what she did, it seemed
like I had hit on something
golden, this is exactly
what I do and what I'm
going to do, in that she was
a prisoner physician and
she also worked as a doctor in a
ghetto.
And then she worked as a doctor
in DP camps, something
that I'm going to hopefully do with
my next project.
So.
That, that was just right
there for me.
And then I realized,
there is a little meat there, but
not very much.
So how, how can I bring
something else to the table
here so I, I can't
really engage in, as I said,
the coercion resistance spectrum
framework because
there's not enough there.
It would, it would be too much of a
reach.
However,
it occurred to me, wait,
I have dealt
with some of these issues
in terms of the macro scale, she
does provide insights
that I can point out.
Odds are people aren't necessarily
going to pick up on, oh, she,
she mentions that the
doctors were supposed to
wear a certain cap
so they wouldn't get shot at.
And,
and Rumkowski brought back
some doctors, or
brought in some doctors from Warsaw.
To me, that signals, wait
a sec.
They want to protect doctors.
The officials want to protect
doctors, and they facilitated
the transfer of doctors from
the Warsaw ghetto to the Lodz
ghetto. Why?
So that, these
are small clues that,
that draw my attention towards
a larger fact.
Of course,
by pointing this out, I'm in
no way negating the horrific
circumstances that
the Jews lived in the Lodz
ghetto.
But the fact that this,
that, that these tiny
details come out
of the testimony, it says something.
And generally, when we're
talking about the,
the horrible conditions,
it wasn't entirely
brought on by
Biebow, the, the head of
the,
the ghetto administration.
There were plenty of people
on other levels
working at cross purposes and
for their own enrichment.
That took food, that took
medication that was meant
for the Jews.
Again, horrible
circumstances.
Odds are the Nazis
were fine with
mass death, but
there was something there
that they wanted to do,
and I see that as
preserving doctors lives
and in some cases letting
medication enter the ghetto
and providing them with minimal
supplies to keep
the workers alive.
That's how Rumkowski kept
the ghetto going.
It was important to the war effort.
So
that, that gives me
some, something to put in the
micro-- I mean, in the macro,
OK.
Did you look at any other doctor
or prisoner physicians
in the collection?
And if so,
what is, why, again, Esther,
if others had more
meat?
Was-- first, the first part
of the question though, did you look
at other physicians and did you find
anything else that could be useful
for your research?
So there are testimonies
of prisoner physicians, however,
they weren't in the regions that
I specialized in, so I
wasn't able to bring to bear the
knowledge of the Warthegau, for
example, which is the location of
the Lodz ghetto.
I had a case study
on the forced-- doctors
in the forced labor camps for Jews
in the Wartegau.
So I have some
grasp of the mechanisms
going on there.
What are the the dynamics?
And,
and I also have a
case study on the--
on doctors in
the industrial subcamp of
Birkenau, which is parallel
to Guben.
So, Guben's relationship to
Gross-Rosen.
So, these
fit better, although,
although the meat wasn't there, I
felt like I could bring more
of what I specialized
in to some extent
to, to bear on,
on the topic.
Whereas other doctors
were in the General Government,
an area that I would love to study
more, but I haven't gotten
there yet, so
that, that's why I chose Esther.
And,
and still, even
though I can't bring what I thought
I could to it, I
still think, and of course you
can weigh in, whether
what I'm bringing is, is substantial
enough in terms of the idea
of macro level
insights and
in micro level activities
and judgments.
Of course, the big thing is that
to me, biggest irony here,
is that by
preserving life, she's helping the
German war effort, which
in the end would want the
destruction of everybody.
And I don't know if that's discussed
a lot, at least in my
reading of the Holocaust.
So, and of course,
the biggest problem was starvation.
I mean, people were dying of
starvation.
She could not,
impact, I guess, unless
that was something that she
brought up to the people in the
camp, that if you don't feed people,
you know, of course, then they have
this endless line of people, that
endless war.
So, I
mean, I don't know how much this is
discussed. This, I mean
it's discussed in terms of
Rumkowski, in terms of his
efforts, which preserves himself.
But this is also going on
at this other level.
You're absolutely right.
In fact, Esther does mention
that her efforts
and
as-- as a doctor for workers
and what the workers were doing
themselves, could be viewed
as collaboration.
She actually mobilizes that
word, which was so
fascinating to me because
there was an awareness that
the effort they put in
on the doctor's part to save the
lives of the workers
who were helping the German
war effort, which, as you pointed
out, would keep the war
going, would pose greater
problems to a larger
Jewish population.
That was an ethical issue.
So
in the
growing scholarship
on, on resistance,
there's discussion
of
people sabotaging in, in
these workplaces, so there was
awareness and, and, and
some of the workers tried to
go in and sabotage
to hurt the--
the war effort.
As for the prisoner physicians
there, of
the ones that I studied, the memoirs
I read, the
testimonies they gave, there
was some awareness that what they
were doing was...
prolong-- potentially contributing
to prolonging the war.
But at the same time,
they were also adhering
to the Hippocratic Oath.
Their job as doctors
was to take
care of patients.
So just doing
what they're supposed to do
had a bigger impact, but
the, the important thing is, is
trying to help the person in front
of them to the greatest extent
possible.
Was there anything particular about
Esther's testimony,
the fact that she was a female
doctor and a pediatrician
that was different from other
testimonies that you looked
at, or does
it put her along
with other female doctors?
I know it's more a deeper research
topic but, just wondering what
you thought of that, whether
you...
It's something that crept into my
mind when I was making the decision.
The, the other testimonies of
doctors were men.
So
generally I'm just a huge fan of
women in medicine,
on-- an underrepresented
group.
And so the fact that I could draw
attention to a woman in medicine,
and a woman in medicine
at that time in the '30s
in Poland, she was overcoming
not just the,
the hurdle of being Jewish with the
numerous clausus, but
being a woman, studying the sciences
and pursuing a
course in medicine.
So she herself addresses
this double problem, which I
find fascinating.
Larry.
Female doctors in Auschwitz-Birkenau
have written that they
were often asked to accompany
the SS men during
selections in the barracks.
And they have written that
they would choose the prisoners
whom they thought were on the verge
of death anyway, they knew that the
people they were choosing to go into
the gas chambers.
Do we know if Esther
knew that people being transported
out of the Lodz ghetto to be
sent to their death rather than to
labor camps, which is the story
that the Germans would tell them?
OK, just based on the last thing,
the story the Germans were telling--
in some cases, they were actually
sent to labor camps.
As far as I can tell from this
testimony-- and I have to spend more
time with the Shoah Foundation
testimony-- as far as I can tell,
she was not on one of the
commissions
for doctors who
looked-- who performed examinations
on people on transport lists.
So that's an important fact.
As for her level of awareness
of what was happening to the people
who left the ghetto,
I'm not sure when
she came to the awareness that
these people just don't come back.
That-- that's unclear.
But she does talk about
the horrific
kinder aktion, the,
the Nazis going in and
taking out all the
the children in
September '42,
and the elderly, and
clearing out the hospitals, and the
violence.
So there's a sense that there's
a major danger,
but
I don't know for sure.
But in my dissertation,
I address
those doctors and, and
what's fascinating is that some
of them didn't want to get involved
in the process in the first place
and they were presented with,
if I may, a choiceless choice.
And
they, they could not
do anything,
which would mean the SS
doctor would pick at random
who was going to the gas chamber
because X number of people
had to come out of the hospital.
And that meant maybe some people
who had a chance of surviving, one,
you know, a person who is one day
away from release
because she
was getting better,
maybe that person would be sent
to the gas chamber, whereas
other people who are about to die
would be left there.
So that was one option.
The other option was
actually participating
in these selections, knowing
who was going to die
of quote unquote, "natural causes,"
very close to death
and
they had no chance of recovery
[INAUDIBLE]
but that was actually acting.
So I,
I'd like to put your term out there,
you have to let me know whether
I'm conceiving of it correctly.
OK, whew,
very relieved there.
OK, we can talk to after
if there are criticisms.
OK.
So, I'm interested in
how you conceptualize resistance,
because in these, in this
concentrationary universe,
all these difficult terms
are up for grabs.
And so I'm interested in
what your working definition is,
if you have one, of resistance?
Well, I believe the
term has been deployed a
bit too much.
When it comes to the extreme
of breathing was resistance
because they were staying alive and
the Nazis wanted to kill them all.
So I back away from that
extreme.
I also back away from the
extreme that the definition
of resistance has to be
armed resistance.
So I'm in
from the extremes.
And
so that much I can say.
I've carved out what's still a
really large area.
I, I,
I eliminate the
acts of resistance
that are perceived by others, but
the person engaged in whatever act
did not
think of his or her action
as resistance.
I look at it as, as something
that, you know, someone
took agency to
resist. There had to be an awareness
of it. So...
Self-awareness.
Yes, thank you. Self-awareness.
So that's one way.
And generally for
me, it's, so it's a self-aware
act that in some
way, to some extent,
would thwart
Nazi aims, so that
that's my working definition.
Thanks.
So you talk a little bit about
during your lecture now, you talk a
little bit about the
interview process itself and the
interaction between the interviewer
and and the witness,
and I kind of wanted to hear
what you had to say about that in
relation to the
spectrum of coercion
and resistance that you're talking
about, because it seems as
if, that
had, have very
large connection, not
only impacted the interviewer
seems to breach Fortunoff
protocols and ask
for for this kind of judgment, but
also the, perhaps
resistance that the,
the witness
kind of portrayed
within the interview itself.
So one thing that I had
as I was looking through
the testimony, I believe they were
Joanne's notes.
And in brackets
in many places along the way,
the comments were like
he's, he's not supposed to ask
that.
How is, how is the witness
supposed to know the answer to
this big historiographical
question?
And I could feel
the frustration.
I'm assuming it's, it's you.
Yeah.
Just like, what is this guy doing?
He is actively inserting
himself. He is asking these big
questions that someone
in, in her own life
and her-- that's what she's the
expert on. That's what she's there
to talk about.
But he was like, oh, yeah,
I read that,
that, you know, the Germans have
this in mind from the beginning.
Well, good for you.
But
this is about Esther.
So, so
it was, it was frustrating for me
and I felt for Joanne through those
notes that she probably
wanted to reach her hand through the
screen.
And I don't know what.
He, he,
as far as I can recall, he didn't
engage once she put that double
bookkeeping out there.
That was a point. He, he, he didn't
latch onto that.
I, I would need to watch
the whole thing in its entirety
again. But
I'm not sure whether he
asked, oh, was there
resistance.
He, based on what I've
pulled, he seemed to be
more fixated on
the, the idea of the collaboration.
But that's a really interesting
point. And another thing
to say in terms of, of
my construction of the
spectrum model,
based on what he's showing, I think
he's nowhere near that conceptual
point of nuance.
He just simply is,
is not there.
So.
So I can't
really bring it into his universe
because he's, he's just not on it.
I'm going to have to...one
more question.
OK.
Were the prisoner doctors,
I sympathize for the decisions
that they had to make at
times.
And I was wondering if they were
sufficiently valuable enough
to the Germans that they were
treated in a way to keep them alive.
That's a great question.
It depends on the camp.
It depends where, when.
Generally they had extra
food.
In some cases that was prescribed,
extra rations, to keep
them alive, to do their doctorly
thing.
In other cases, it was,
they ate the food
for prisoners
who couldn't eat it.
And they also shared it with, with
people in the barracks, so,
so generally they
were pretty well fed.
The fact, just the fact that they
worked inside as opposed
to on outside labor commando,
that kept them alive longer
to, to do what they were doing.
And because
they didn't work under
the cruel, watchful
eye of a horrible
kapo, they were generally
under under
the watch of a head
doctor, whether it's a Jewish
doctor or not, the
business within these,
they were called hospitals or
clinics or...
Revier.
Yeah.
Yes, that's the term that comes up,
I'm try-- and Häftlings
Krankenbauer, Krankenbauer, KB,
so yeah.
So I'm just trying to translate the,
the different meanings.
So.
They, they weren't exposed to the
same kind of violence.
So how conscious
of a decision that
was on the part of
camp leadership, I
can't tell you,
but it was a fact that they
were spared some of the disastrous,
horrific, horrific circumstances
that the average prisoner
had to confront.
I just want to address this
point, I think the most important
thing you said was in the beginning
and
[INAUDIBLE] plenty of doctors
were selected as soon as they
arrived, for death, even though
they were known to be physicians.
Then it just depended where and
when.
Maybe [INAUDIBLE] too.
No, it was, it's, just, what was
happening at that moment in time.
You know, it's so random,
it's, it's not systematic,
we always think the Nazi
regime was rational,
systematic, it was not.
It was actually quite chaotic.
Not in the Warthegau when it came to
doctors.
Right. So so,
yes,
I've seen testimonies
of people whose parents
were physicians.
Yes.
And the person selecting them knew
they were physicians--
But said, you're too, you're too
old. You've lived.
There's one--
But they were sent to death.
There's one testimony.
I think her name is Gertrude
Mossberg.
She said, Oh, but my father's a
physician.
Oh, how old is he?
And she states the age.
Oh, he's lived long enough.
So you're, you're right.
But at the same time,
again, depending on when,
if we're talking, if we're talking
Birkenau.
There was a stage when
the SS physicians
performing selections
were told to spare
the lives of Jewish doctors, and
this was in '44 when labor
was crucial.
And those people
were transferred
from Birkenau
to Monowitz, to
the other subcamps, so there
was a concerted effort
and you could see in
the documentation, this person,
this doctor is transferred on the
order of the
head physician,
the head SS physician.
So, so you're
right. It changed.
But there were
attempts at systematizing
the selection, the positive
selection of, of doctors.
OK, well, thank you, Sari.